[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's been no growth in the film and
television business like stunts now you
have second unit and stunt coordinators
directing movies hugely successful
um the the things that the creativity
and the Ingenuity that the stunt
Community pulls off in both television
and film is is unprecedented the growth
it's it's constantly one-upping itself
and it's unbelievably uh unrecognized by
the entertainment system in a number of
ways but also just the way that the
stunt the the way that like it works as
a stunt guy talk about the hustle of
being a stunt guy and like just like how
[ __ ] hard that is and like what how
that goes down you basically just got to
show up on sets right and just be like
yo you don't know anything to get a job
to get a job I mean like just just talk
because I think people think you know to
be an actor or whatever it is which is
its own [ __ ] struggle whatever yeah
but it's like you know you got to get an
age you got to get a marriage but like
some guys it's like you know you'll be
honest I'm always hanging out with the
stun team it's like every day you'll see
guys go they just walk it's like walking
into a gym like hey man I'm looking for
a fight yeah I mean like that that's
what being a stunt guy is like talk
about that hustle and then there's all
these factions there's like gangs I mean
it's like you know what I mean there's
right you know what I mean it's like
well you're down with each other exactly
exactly exactly exactly and they talk
about they talk a lot more [ __ ] right
yeah because a lot of them don't have
the real so yeah talk a little bit about
that a little bit man first of all
stunts changed my life stunts gave me a
life man like like Tom Lowell in Chicago
the greatest stunt coordinator I know
he's just a man uh gave me a chance but
um yeah so like how you get jobs in
stunts is you got to do what's it's
literally the industry term is hustling
right and it means something different
for stunt people than it does for
everybody else for sure so when you're
hustling
as a stunt performer woman or man right
you got to find out where they're
shooting something so let's say
[ __ ] Punisher
is is shooting you know what I mean what
let's just say they were shooting out
here in Santa Clarita right okay
and I find out my buddy's working on it
I tell I text my buddy I says hey
let me get the address uh you got the
call sheet so they'll do what they're
not supposed to do when you send me the
call sheet right now I got the base camp
right which is where all you can't let
anybody know that you got it from that
person right no that's [ __ ] that's
that's sacred you could never do that
you're you [ __ ] excommunicated but uh
so you get and they're not gonna ask you
here's the thing
it's like an unspoken thing nobody asks
you where'd you get the info they just
it's like it's like you were meant to be
there it's crazy like I've
so then I'll get so then the stunned
person will then have to go to that
location somehow get on set somehow
somehow get on set yeah I have done the
craziest [ __ ] I have climbed fences I've
scaled walls yeah
I've broken and entered so many times
yeah I've I've climbed under fences the
the gnarliest one was out in the valley
in like Agua Dulce or some [ __ ] and I
parked my car on like the freeway
somewhere and I hiked up to the location
because they had a security guard
sitting
like at the entrance to this Ranch and I
had my phone talking to nobody right
pretending I'm walking from I mean if
this guy had any like if he would have
been like paying attention he would have
been like why the [ __ ] is this guy
walking from the highway from the 210.
I'm like hey how are you doing pal and I
give him away how you doing buddy and
keep walking now I walk like a mile up
to where the working trucks are which
are which are the trucks that carry all
the equipment that's not base camp where
all the actors are so now I get to the
working trucks I'm stressed because I
don't know where the [ __ ] they're
filming I see little golf carts driving
up to the location and I'm like [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] everybody's on golf carts I'm
on foot I'm gonna look suspicious and
then I see a couple pas
after like an hour of me hanging out by
the portal potties you know what I mean
like in the portal potty like pretend go
to the bathroom I spy a couple Pas
running up to set so I go run up with
them like I'm a PA and I get up to set
and then the stunt coordinator who I
will not name yeah
what's cool as [ __ ]
he sees you I have my head shot and
resume tucked in my pants yeah before
you know they now they do email but at
the time you have your real [ __ ] yeah
have your [ __ ] on you yeah I got this
[ __ ] stuffed in My Pan I'm running up
with him like a half mile sweating in
the in the desert and we get up there
and they're doing like a shootout right
so I'm like I'm like hanging back they
get to shoot out they call cut
I don't know what the stunt coordinator
looks like so I'm on IMDb barely have a
signal see the [ __ ] picture of the
guy okay what I'm trying to find this
[ __ ] I see him I walk to I knock
him on the shoulder I go uh I go Hey sir
how you doing I'm Sammy Horowitz I'm a
you know Pro fighter trying to uh get a
job
he looks at me like like I was invited
in this [ __ ] like I got driven
up oh hey Sammy thanks for stopping by
yeah it's a job interview yeah glad you
can stop yeah buddy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah thank you for your interest can I
drop off my uh stuff dude yeah sure oh I
see you work for so-and-so Oh that's oh
he's my pal yeah yeah he's a good guy
okay great hey I'll try to give you a
call and then you pray that you'll get a
job which fortunately for me that's what
got me in out here in La is I just I did
this over and over and over again and
and sometimes you go and people like get
the [ __ ] out of here right like
sometimes you're met with not with
hostility or like because I the the the
community can also I've seen the
community be like man who is this clown
kind of thing just like anything so
thank God that has not happened to me
yeah yeah thank God it has not happened
yet it's not happened to me yeah
um every every coordinator I'm not
saying all the coordinators have been
like buddy buddy hey buddy but every
coordinator male or female have huge
really met me with respect
and like it's always comical because
they always act like you didn't just
break Five Laws to get there
excuse me but yeah they're they're all
they've all been cool with me but I've
heard horror stories though of like
coordinators ripping up headshots in
front of them get the [ __ ] out of here
you know what I mean I've seen that yeah
thank God that didn't happen to me yeah
yeah for sure for sure and what do you
think just the state I mean I want
there's so much more I want to talk to
you about but what do you think just in
the sort of like the state of stunts you
know like one one of the things that
you know I I go back to a lot man is is
is is John you know he passed on the set
of The Walking Dead I don't know if you
you know about that dude and and I'm I'm
friends with his with with John
bernickers with a very good friend I I
know him and I and and I obviously
didn't work on The Walking Dead
um but I'm familiar with what happened
and uh and I think every stun person is
familiar with what happened and uh we
all
it was a [ __ ] tragedy I mean can you
I'm curious just from being in the
community it's like I know the story
both from the community and I know the
story from you know the folks involved
in The Walking Dead for the sort of and
I'm just wondering I'm really interested
in the what what what was the story in
your mind like what have you what have
you heard that went down with John
I mean
you know obviously inarguably he was a
ridiculously talented he was extremely
talented I don't know him and I kind of
feel uncomfortable speaking about it
because I don't know I wasn't there
I wasn't there but at the end of the day
the coordinator is responsible for for
what happens on those things and that
coordinator
it was responsible for what happened uh
I don't you know and and that was a
tragedy and it shouldn't have happened
and you know every single person I've
ever talked about or I've ever talked to
about
him John bernicker told me that he was
incredibly gifted and talented I knew
that I mean I can tell you that and so
that shouldn't happen and it was so so
being somebody that's that's taught that
I don't want to speak too much on
something I don't know but I will say
that all I will say is that the
coordinator is responsible when those
type of things happen
and that's why coordinators are so
important the reason I bring it up with
you Sammy is because
you know the story I'll talk about I
mean the story that that that I heard I
mean we we know we know how he passed
yeah he did a roof jump right and a high
fall right and what a couple still like
20 feet something like that something
that you know for a trained stunt guy
like John is is uh is not a huge not not
a huge son so I've done that you know
and and uh there was some what we can't
what we can't know whether there was
some contact with the actor but what we
do know is that it was the end of the
night and a lot of times on these shows
the stunts to save money are moved to
the very end of the night even though
it's by Far and Away the most dangerous
thing that you're going to be doing all
day but it's sort of the last thing and
that's when I was sort of like to
disrespect that goes to the stun
Community it's sort of like okay you're
this extra thing that goes in the end
yeah but as we I was on the show Walking
Dead and Punisher it's enormously stun
heavy I mean you could argue that people
watch The Punisher not for me being
[ __ ] all angry and [ __ ] they watch it
for the fight item for the action okay
that's it and so it's it so if if you're
if half the audience is if at least half
the audience is tuning in for that you
would think that they would be given the
the the respect and the time
um you know to honor the previous to
honor both the safety and the creativity
of the team that's making it but that
stunt was moved to to deep deep into the
end of the night and the story that I've
been told by multiple people is that you
know anytime you do a high fall like
that you position stunt men or stunt
people on the corners of the bag so if
you're falling off there's a there's a
big uh a pad a big giant mat that you're
falling into and that you have airbag or
airbag but you have trained stunt people
on all Corners just in case there's a
mistake you can move it and what I heard
is that those people were on all four
corners and a producer had walked by and
asked what they were doing there because
they were moving it to the end of the
night so the producer said we're not
paying for these people to be sitting
around here all night and that they were
released have you heard that no so
that's the story that got back to me
that these people were told to go
[ __ ] should be never work again
if that's true
so if that if that if that's true those
people should never work that that but
that that sounds like it could that
sounds like something it's a story I
heard and then John you know John uh you
know on the night was up there uh uh
with an actor that I know and it was
during rehearsal wasn't even the stunt
again that's that's that's what I heard
and there was some contact and there was
supposed to be no contact and you tried
to write the fall that's what I heard
and he missed the bag by two feet since
there was no safety yeah uh you know he
he he died and and you're like
these things happen like way more than I
think anybody has any idea you know I
mean people get I mean stuff absolutely
some folks are getting seriously injured
and often which is why stunt people get
paid extra for exactly and and if
there's an injury you get paid extra
um
you know and then you know there's a lot
of about sort of how it was dealt with
afterwards which was which was pretty
disgusting too you know what I'm saying
yeah and also you know that coordinator
is still working
still on that show and I mean I don't
know if that show's still going honestly
but it's the last year yeah yeah I mean
like you know I'm pretty sure you're
still there not I don't I've never met
the man uh but you know it just
money talk you know Hollywood's uh
I'm gonna say I mean I make a living in
it you know
but it's it's it's it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
up business where people try to cut
Corners a lot and the one thing that
shouldn't be
that corner should not be cut in safety
is safety happens and having and having
the right people for the job that can
that can perform a job and in John's
case he was the right person but I'm
talking about in that case having stunt
safeties
there when they should have been there
not you know you know what else can I
say on it I mean I I've been I've been
blessed that I've worked around a lot of
great people and and thankfully the
shows that I've worked on the movies
I've worked on I've worked on with some
of the the best coordinators and and and
who have fought
for their performers no we're gonna that
person needs to [ __ ] be here [ __ ]
your overtime they're gonna [ __ ] work
you know thankfully I've been on those
shows you know but I've heard about the
horror stories of the the coordinators
that get ran over and just like okay
yeah okay sure yeah
[Music]